Joy read on MSNBC has her own reaction
to the Grammys where she's sort of
spiking the cultural football
um
and it's uh taking it in a different
direction from where a lot of our
compatriots on the left have done and
she says a few things here that that are
unintentionally kind of interesting so I
want to play this clip
I hadn't watched in years but I really
enjoyed it
just did it was to put it mildly a
celebration of the very thing the
American right has turned into its
latest anti-wokness Boogeyman diversity
equity and inclusion
the show opened with Puerto Rican singer
Bad Bunny singing 99 in Spanish then
host Trevor Noah walked and talked
through a room that was diversity equity
and inclusion in human form
the first country Americana artist to
perform
he walked so the room at the Grammys
he's also he's walking down in the room
with all the famous people that's
diversity equity and inclusion in uh in
incarnate that's what that's really so
it's a bunch of really rich Elite people
from the same socioeconomic uh with the
same socodynamic status the same kind of
cultural Stratosphere
um and who all believe the same things
and are are you know identical
ideologically that's diversity Equity
inclusion a bunch of Rich very rich
wealthy prominent
um
people who all agree with each other is
diversity and Equity inclusion she's
right actually that is that is
what Dei is all about it's just
interesting to hear her admit that but
was introduced by her wife and daughters
we saw the first trans artist when a
Grammy Kim Petras who has a hit song
with Sam Smith the British singer who
came out in 2019 as non-binary black
acting Superstar Viola Davis became an
egot winning a Grammy to add to her
Golden Globe Oscar and Tony Awards lizzo
performed with her amazing choir of many
sized singers
Beyonce took home her 32nd Grammy to
become the most Grammy decorated singer
of all time best thing and I had to look
this up Hungarian British conductor
George salty
record of the year went to Harry Styles
a British male singer who frequently
puts on dresses to pose in magazines and
is a sex symbol to women and men because
of it
and there was a 15-minute epic tribute
to the 50th anniversary of hip-hop so
yeah
the culture wars are over and the left
one like total defeat I can only imagine
the heads exploding in red States I
imagine Ron DeSantis is somewhere
stalking through his Governor's Mansion
trying to figure out how to ban the
Airing of the Grammys in Florida and
take away cbs's tax exemptions no
educational value queer Theory black
music
it's a helpful reminder that despite the
almost external War the right is waging
to take the culture all right good so
you heard that now
a couple of things here so as I said
she's she's sort of uh
spiking the football and saying well you
see so the left one the culture War
okay well that's true
Joy then to begin with can you stop
acting persecuted
you just said you won
you won right and that means there's no
more systemic racism or sexism or any of
the rest of it because you won you won
the culture you took over
and and that's if if you want to take
the approach of bragging about it and
say you see we won
a fine I think that's actually a much
more honest approach
but then you can't in the very next
breath say and we're so we won we run
everything and we're persecuted
we're the Champions and we're oppressed
like you can't do that you have to you
have to choose a lane so are you the
football spiking Victors are you you're
dancing on the graves of your Fallen
enemies
are you that
as you portray here or are you uh uh
practically still you know in Chains
enslaved uh nothing's gotten better it's
it in fact it's gotten worse and you're
oppressed and so your your
intersectional you know you're black and
you're a female so you're oppressed in
many different ways with different
angles which one it cannot be both Joy
it can't be both
so you have to choose
um
and I'll tell you which one is the
correct one it's it's it's well
it's sort of the first option that you
want it's sort of that
um
you did win
the institutions
so you're right you did you won the
institutions you claimed the
institutions
institutionally
it isn't it's an all-out Victory as you
say
the Grammys are institutional they are
an Institutional award show it is the
it's the music industry is a billion
dollar industry a billion multi-billion
dollar institution awarding itself you
know congratulating itself
and
other people with institutional power
like yourself are are very interested in
the Grammys while while you know people
that do not have institutional power
just regular people look at this
spectacle and say like why should I care
about this at all
so that's what you want you won the
institutions
and from there you know the institutions
that have been all ideologically
captured every single one
from there the institutions are trying
to impose themselves and impose the
left-wing worldview on the population
and as far as that goes as far as the
population goes
um you do have an enormous advantage
because you again you run all the
institutions that people need and people
rely on and and turn to and uh you
control the flow of information you
control a lot of stuff
and that gives you an enormous Advantage
when it comes to
capturing the people's minds and hearts
as well but it has not been an all-out
Victory there not quite
even with this advantage
and um
it it especially on some of the more
recent efforts
you know so like institutionally
you can we
can give an award to uh two biological
males and claim that there's something
other than male and so therefore this is
a great victory for diversity or
whatever and the institutions will give
that award and other people within the
institutions will applaud that and say
isn't that so beautiful such a wonderful
thing
but regular people
most of them they look at that and
they're not so convinced
they look at you know chubby Sam Smith
and and we're told that he's well no
he's not a male he's non-binary what
what is that
that's what regular people say they're
not convinced
and even though there are potentially
incredible consequences for not for
failing to be convinced like we're
punished for not being convinced and
still
most people aren't
and most people also are certainly not
convinced
that Tim Petros who now calls himself
Kim Petras is actually a woman
because uh he was mutilated at the age
of 16.
the idea that mutilation makes a woman
or that his uh his perception of himself
as a woman makes him one
people aren't convinced by that either
so you do have the institutions
the question is whether you can capture
everyone's minds and souls from there
that's what you're trying to do
you haven't quite succeeded
and uh that's where the battle is going
to really be won or lost
but I'm glad we can agree again
that you are not oppressed
that you are in a position of power that
you own the institutions
that you are you you have now
um uh you now claim incredible status
and privilege and power I'm glad you're
finally admitting that
so stop whining
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to members block
hope to see you there if not we'll talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]